Sonia is with me in Minneapolis hi Sonia
how are you I'm doing good how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up in
your warmth well I had a quick question
for you maybe it's not super quick but
in essence should I lend my fiance a
huge chunk of money no you pay off okay
absolutely not no okay the borrower is
slave to the lender if you want to turn
your fiance into your slave loaning
money you will change the quality and
the tone and the tenor of your
relationship yeah the old the old joke
is if you loan your brother-in-law 100
dollars and he never speaks to you again
was it worth it that's the old joke I
mean you change the way people treat
each other when are you getting married
we don't know that yeah because of money
well no no not necessarily just because
of that but it's just we're trying to
get him to a place first where we can
kind of both be comfortable with it all
and yeah so how much money are you do
you have that how much money do you have
I have over $30,000 and how much does
seen how much were you going to loan him
21 okay to do what pay off credit cards
and stuff instead of filing bankruptcy
that's kind of what the last part of
that coil anchor up see on $21,000 oh I
don't know I've never done it myself I'm
pretty much debt-free and always have
been very good with my money - does he
have an income oh he does he is our
actual bread maker of the home I want to
say 57 right here okay well you're not
bankrupt if you only owe $21,000 you
make fifty seven thousand dollars a year
well okay
actually let me go back that's just the
credit cards
there's student loans that aren't
involved okay let's say in essence 51
with student loans are being run double
right and I know that and that's why I
was
so you would file bankruptcy on $21,000
making 57 that's just absurd
well kind of yeah I didn't know what
route to say because he's actually
drowning right now he is um he's not
making enough to cover all his bills and
I hope yes he is on his car
um he has a truck that is that 11,000 is
the balance Humble over 11,000 okay and
how much does he owe on estrada cards
the credit cards alone is the 21,000
yeah and how much on the student loans
about nine thousand okay well people
call in here every day making 60,000
that pay off fifty thousand dollars in
debt
take some a couple couple years they
have to get organized they have to get
on a budget and an hour sounds like
y'all are living together yeah we own a
house we own a home we bought a house
you're both doing the payments you're
both only what do you make a year I
don't I'm a failure mom I don't work
it's time for y'all to get married and
quit playing around with this and get on
the same page and start running a budget
and let's crank this down and then you
put your money in the pot and you clean
this mess up together but that has to be
with him getting organized in the to you
bein on a budget you can't act like your
roommates and then be having kids and
ullman houses together you're not
freaking roommates this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]